foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
how dare they mugshot America's mayor
you're not America's mayor Rudy
[Music]
stop trying
to live on 9 11 still you're a [__]
traitor that's what you are
Rudy Giuliani Grandpa farty mcsharty
Rudy colludy
he's gonna turn himself in today so did
cheeseburger our cheese burrow
now these cast of characters found out
yesterday that one of the Trump
Mar-A-Lago employees
turned State evidence decided that hey
probably isn't a good idea for me to be
uh represented by a a trump paid
attorney I should probably get an
attorney who's actually working in my
interest and I'm going to change my
false testimony that I made in front of
the grand jury
to save my ass likely this employee I
think it's employee number four isn't
that which one it is I don't know
hey you lose track after 91 felony
counts what the [__] are you supposed to
do once we get to over a hundred oh
there's going to be over 100 felony
counts against Trump
100 percent there's gonna be over a
hundred don't you think I think you'll
get nine more on superseding indictments
we'll see we'll find out
and oh the debate is tonight
okay so I was listening this morning to
the media and
they they were they were saying they
were saying that Chris Christie is the
perfect wedge uh to to drive between the
Republican party and Trump
it almost feels like they stole that
from somewhere and then
it's almost like they stole that
sounds like someone has been saying that
for I don't know a couple months now and
Chris Christie was gonna be the best
kind of wedge
to drive down into the Republican party
I don't know maybe maybe maybe a guy
who's on every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central
maybe he would say I have something to
say about it for a couple hours a day
it's almost like you know
if you would just come here and listen
first you wouldn't have to listen to
that [__] trash of the media yeah
that's right I'm I look I'm not gonna
call the media the Enemy of the State
I'm just saying that because they're not
but what they are is [__] bad at
their jobs they're horrible at it
they're horrible you know because here's
the problem even with what where you
have the situation today with all these
defendants surrendering which I'm gonna
get to Mark Meadows I actually think she
he's going to make fonnie Willis arrest
him
um
but they they just they just don't get
it they just don't get it and the reason
why they don't is because the media
always wants to be correct right and
what I mean by that is they want to say
the thing and then to make you feel good
the audience and then that thing
happened
right that's what they want they want to
deliver the results for you and that is
not their job
that is not their job their job is not
to deliver results
that's not their job their job is to
report the [__] news and stick to the
goddamn truth and the facts not how you
feel about it not how you want to feel
about it
that's what Fox News oan and Newsmax
does
they they Pander to an audience in a way
of how they feel and what you believe
that ain't the truth that ain't the
[__] facts
so so again I say I don't think the
media's uh evil right like the right
Wingers do they all heard a big
conspiracy about George Soros and the
lasers and they're gonna come get you
and they're trying to brainwash you even
though I'm watching television that is
designed to brainwash me is what is the
truth about Maga but I'm not saying the
mainstream media is brainwashing people
what I'm saying is they're not good at
their job
and the reason why we have Trump he's
not he's not the [__] he's not the
disease he's the symptom of the disease
and the disease is [__] delusion and
misinformation
and the media is so [__] scared so
terrified to appear biased again biased
what to the [__] truth
Jesus Christ this morning again they're
reporting that Chris Christie is the
best wedge in this debate to drive down
and make sure Donald Trump loses the
general election
hey can you can
we can rewind and and figure out if I'd
been saying that
the reason why I've been saying that is
because I don't know I pay attention
and I use my [__] couple brain cells
that I got left from all the drugs and
alcohol that I've done and I just use
those what I have left to [__] come
up with the logical conclusion of how
this is working
foreign
that Chris Christie is not just
receiving money from Republicans but
Democrats as well
Jesus Christ Dr Rachel bittacopper was
posting on Twitter [__] give him
money
so he can get on stage
and the reason why is because he is the
best wedge to drive down in between
these Republicans and we're going to see
it tonight in action
that's probably going to be some of the
best clips that come out of the
Republican debate
when Chris Christie destroys Ron
DeSantis he destroys vivec because vivec
won't punch on Trump
and all the other [__] irrelevant
people that are going to be standing on
stage
and they all have their purpose
Christie's purpose for us us
pro-democracy people is not to support
him and not to think that he would be a
great president or that we ever want him
to be anywhere near the office of
President the point is to use him as a
political weapon
against themselves they've done this to
themselves folks
and this is why the media again is not
doing their job because they don't just
[__] tell you the truth
they got to be right they got to be
correct and it's not about being factual
or reporting the facts
that's why that's why on the advantage
thing I'm misleading information I'm not
misleading anyone I'm telling you what I
think is gonna happen I'm not I don't
I'm not an actual fortune teller
I just look at the political landscape
know the history of bile dicks I kind of
have my my thumb on the heartbeat of
America to some degree and I just I'm
guessing
but I guess correctly because I'm again
I'm not I'm not [__] worried about
whether you're going to be mad at me
or not or if you're gonna be upset oh my
God Tony was wrong about this thing I'll
never watch him again good hit the
[__] road Jack
I'm not gonna be biased just to be
biased I'm not gonna
do things so I don't appear biased
this is why Trump and his allies are all
surrendering this week
you realize that right is because on the
right wing they have to capitulate
it's the reason why you watch media and
you're like why are they saying this
because they're capitulating to some
degree to the right wing to [__] lies
lies [__] lies Jesus Christ I'm gonna
show you a clip today of Kevin McCarthy
going on Fox News and talking about how
a president has never [__] received
foreign money and [__] like what are you
talking about man
the guy that you [__] went down to
Mar-A-Lago and gave fellatio to so you
could be speaker of the house is exactly
as you describe Jesus Christ on Fox News
they're acting like Joe Biden is the
worst person in the entire world because
he pet a dog
I'm not [__] you he pet a dog in in
Hawaii you know they were like oh my God
why isn't President Biden in Hawaii
because it's a [__] natural disaster
area you dumb [__] and the last
thing Hawaii needed at the time at that
moment really even yesterday
they needed the distraction of
protecting a president on the island
why the [__] do they need to spend
resources to do that [__] for a photo op
I think it's dumb I actually think the
White House made a real big mistake for
Biden to go to that place they need the
presidents need to stop doing that [__]
during national disasters [__] that [__]
there is plenty of people on the ground
to give a report and brief a president
of the United States we need to be
wasting [__] resources for one person
to go to a Goddamn place so they can
take a picture it's ridiculous
but Fox News bitching about Biden not
being in Hawaii he goes to Hawaii he
pets a search dog he oh my God he likes
he likes dogs
Fox News loses their mind I'm not
kidding you loses their [__] mind
because he pet the dog and he said man
this ground is hot he meant it's hot
outside and the dog has its bare feet on
the ground
how dare he have empathy for a dog
Republicans apparently hate [__] dogs
I don't know if you know this I didn't I
didn't really I knew Trump hated [__]
dogs
but Republicans apparently across the
board right-wingers are now anti-dog
because Joe Biden petted one so now I
dogs are canceled they're gonna boycott
[__] they're gonna boycott canines
because Joe Biden pet one Jesus [__]
Christ are you kidding me
that's what they're [__] freaking out
about this morning that Biden went to
Hawaii
do you see do you see wine do you see
why
I continue to do what I do because the
media the media is not is not going to
play well with that story because what
they're going to be like is like Yeah
Joe Biden he really should have went he
shouldn't have went to Hawaii I'm
actually criticizing him he should not
have went to Hawaii no President should
show up at a national disaster within
six months of that National disaster the
President should go check up on FEMA and
the state agencies that are rebuilding
in these areas whether it be a flood a
fire a tornado a hurricane whatever it
is
he shouldn't be assessing the damage on
the ground and taking away resources
what he should be doing or she should be
doing and really maybe that's the
[__] problem here maybe that's really
the problem is all the [__]
presidents up to this point have a dick
contest to [__] compete with when a
woman being present wouldn't [__] do
dick contest [__]
maybe that's why we should really
consider this next time having a [__]
woman to clean up the [__] mess that
men have made in this country for over
200 years
but the right wing in the media you're
not they're not gonna they're not oh the
media's gonna be like they're really
upset that Joe Biden has empathy
and I'm not saying he doesn't I'm not
saying it's a bad thing that he went I'm
just saying he shouldn't have they
shouldn't have went they shouldn't have
went fell for the [__] pressure of
the right wing
Democrats and the left and liberals and
the media need to stop with that
[__] [__] them [__] them we do not
have to follow their lead we do not have
to get baited by their stupid [__]
media traps [__] them
[__] em
and I'm telling you if we don't stop
with the media traps that these [__]
idiots set
it is gonna cause us to lose gains in
our democracy
[__] we've lost enough
it's 2016. three Supreme Court Justices
stripped stripped women's rights away
for health care in this country
set the groundwork for [__] fascists
all over this country in red states to
chip away at their right to health care
and their right to privacy with their
[__] doctor
you don't think there's consequences in
capitulating to these [__] Nazis
there's [__] consequences around
every goddamn corner and that is why
it's so important to show these [__]
mug shots [__] them make them public I
am glad that the Fulton County Sheriff
says I don't give a [__] who you are
when you come in my jail you get [__]
mug shot that's how it works [__] you
and everyone else
wouldn't you love to be a fly
in the room in the processing room when
Trump's in there because you know that
because he's already trying to get
secret service to [__] run roadblock
on a mug shot [__] that [__]
he and he's gonna be in that processing
room really trying to talk those guys uh
I I backed the blue I love the police
law enforcement and blah blah blah blah
blah Lauren order Law and Order
no obstruction no clue it's all with
tent you know it's the Witch Hunt you
being police officers I bet the blue
you know that's the [__] he's gonna do
in the room to try to make sure they
don't mugshot him
and they should look at him and say [__]
you stand over there you fat old fart
stand over there in front of that
[__] that [__] measuring stick get
on this [__] scale
you're treated just like any other
[__] you're under arrest you're
being detained shut your [__] mouth
that's how they should treat him like
the piece of trash he is [__] them
oh cops love to treat other human beings
like trash we all know that
oh they [__] love it it's like a
Pastime for them
I hope they make that past time all up
and down his ass make him take his
jacket off and his tie DNA test him oh
man it's a [__] when someone makes you
[__] open your mouth and sticks
cotton swabs in your mouth
to take your saliva your DNA
make him do the fingerprints the old way
not digital [__] Inc ink him up
[__] with his hair before they take the
picture you goddamn right rough him up a
bit you know [__] slam their head
into the car as you put them in and that
what one guy said before huh isn't that
what he said before in that what in that
I think we got a tape of some
[__] saying can you grab that
for me
you know what I'm talking about
so yeah I'm excited that there's mug
shots I'm excited that Rudy Giuliani is
[__] whining and crying about how
America's mayor oh I convicted all these
criminals
it's historic of the work I did maybe
you should have learned your lesson and
not committed the crime that they
committed
Rico
Ricola
maybe if you knew anything about the
RICO law Rudy you wouldn't have [__]
broke it dumbass
but it's going to be a hell of a week oh
man we're only it's only [__]
Wednesday
oh we got a lot to go here
again we got the [__] show the clown
show tonight on Fox News in Wisconsin
you're gonna watch uh Chris Christie
beat the hell out of every single one of
these idiots
that's that's what that's what I'm for
that's what the show I'm looking for is
for Chris Christie to absolutely
beat the ever loving [__] out of Ron
DeSantis and vivec the other ones I mean
it's not gonna take much they're
probably not gonna say much they're
probably not going to get a word in
edgewise
Pence
Haley Tim Scott Asha Asha Hutchinson
what's the um what's the guy from up
North and there's some kind of Governor
from up North that's running what the
[__] his name is it South Dakota
governor North Dakota I don't know
I don't know some some [__]
I don't know did you hear that Larry
Elder is running for president I guess
he's pissed off that he's not on the
debate stage or some [__]
they weren't using the Rasmussen poll
as a measuring stick for him to get on
the stage and he's really pissed you
remember Larry Elder
you remember this guy the token black
guy from from California
pretends he's a Nazi he was he was
trying to run against Gavin Newsom in
the uh
in in the uh in the race to try to
unseat Gavin Newsom to recall him
that guy he's our talk show radio host
why do why do people who who commentate
think that they make make good
politicians
I've got that a lot of people getting my
comments or like Tony you should run for
Congress no no no no
see that's what's wrong with their side
is they get the clowns to run
the clowns should clown
[Music]
what do you think my job is everyone's
like oh add font is specifically is like
oh you're you're the news no no I'm not
news I'm making fun of the news
[Laughter]
oh [__]
hell but that's how it goes that's how
it goes so tonight tonight we're gonna
have plenty of Clips
um that are gonna be tomorrow and
tomorrow speaking of tomorrow I've got a
great guest tomorrow uh we're gonna have
Tennessee Brando on at the bottom of the
hour so don't forget to tune in tomorrow
we're gonna have Tennessee Brando on
we're going to talk a little more about
some of these uh these songs that have
come out
not just his but others that are being
debated and becoming means all over the
internet
so we'll and we'll we'll follow up with
how Jason Aldean song [__] the bed
um and how all these other songs posing
as the plight of Appalachia isn't
actually the plight of Appalachia
so we'll we'll uh we'll talk about some
of that
as well tomorrow so make sure to tune in
don't forget to subscribe here on
YouTube
to the Tony Michaels podcast it's free
99 it doesn't cost you a single dime
uh to subscribe and hit the like button
that doesn't cost anything either now if
you want to get a super chat in I know
YouTube hates my guns I was watching a
video yesterday of some right wing some
right-wing misogynistic you know Woman
Haters Club Channel on YouTube I guess
they lost their monetization and they
were crying about it and whining about
it Jesus Christ why are you whining
crying YouTube owns the [__] thing
what are you supposed to do
I mean I tried they don't want they
don't like me I've told you YouTube
doesn't [__] like me yesterday was it
yesterday or day before anyway yesterday
before I even started really they made
my episode uh uh adult content adult
only 18 plus before I was even done they
were doing that to me
whatever whatever the [__] they want to
do but if you want a Super Chat the only
way that we get to do it on on YouTube
because they again they hate my guts is
do a venmo chat venmo Super Chat go to
thetonymichaels.com that's right you go
to the Tony michaels.com you can type in
you can see the link there at the top
for the the venmo Super Chat uh we'll
bring your your comment up on the show
here if you uh venmo me I put the link
in the chat right there if you want to
do that if you want to venmo chat me now
get in on that also don't forget to go
to the Discord where the chat party
never stops
oh my God it's hopping over there this
morning there was a troll and uh
there is a troll
oh God if the troll um watch the show
which they used to they used to come and
you know get get in on the um
get on the action here but a troll
showed up in the Discord this morning
and they were talking about my old drive
through videos now we've been through
this before there's a bunch of [__]
uh
in cells on the internet that really
really really did not like my
drive-through videos from years ago it's
like from yeah they got to be from at
least five years ago or more
they didn't really like them
they [__] hated them and you can go
find on the internet where these [__]
boxes are trying to trying to act like
trying to act like those videos are what
this channel is about now
here's the thing
the reason they don't know this but the
reason why I took them down is just to
piss them off that's it that's the only
reason why I took them down because they
they got pissed that I took them down so
I kept them down [__] them
and this troll came in this morning
talking that and then they started they
started getting really they started
getting really shitty look I don't mind
trolls I don't as long as they behave
you start threatening people's lives and
[__]
that's where I draw the line you start
being a [__] outright Nazi nah that's
enough we're [__] show you to the
door and open the door with your [__]
head
so this morning that's what happened
they were messing around with the troll
in the Discord and then uh and then the
moderators
um rough them up on the way out and
tossed them out on the sidewalk on them
yeah and Chris Christopher's got it
right here on YouTube they call Tony
mcnuggies you know they like they don't
they don't even see they all used to
make fun of this sign see it says nugs
not drugs like I'm not hiding it I'm not
hiding you know what you know what I
might do
I might go ahead and make those videos
public for just like a couple hours just
a couple hours and then turn it back off
it's so funny because they actually
think I'm embarrassed by them but what
they don't know is I really the only
reason why I got them often because it
pisses them off and they come and they
[__] like on Twitter they're always
asking what happened to the
drive-through videos like
keep commenting keep giving the
algorithm comments good and give a [__]
ah they're funny as [__] though
trolls so go go over to the Discord and
there hasn't been too many uh trolls uh
making appearance at Discord but they're
starting to they're starting to catch on
and the link is in the Chant there to go
to the uh the Discord you can also watch
on Twitch there's a lively chat over on
Twitch twitch.tv slash D Tony Michaels
and you can watch on Facebook too empty
Tony Michaels just go to
thetonymichaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com for all the
links where you can see me everywhere
because you're not going to want to miss
a single episode of this show also if I
can ask a favor of you go download the
audio version every afternoon on Apple
Spotify goo it's free to download it it
helps us out especially if you do it on
Apple if you got Apple go download it I
think it usually if you can set it to
automatically download it I believe I
think so I'm not I'm not exactly sure
how all that works
I'm not I'm not that good and you know
that's how it goes that's how it goes uh
we're gonna stick around uh I think I'm
gonna do a shoot the [__] here for a
little bit while we wait for Gabe's
inches so stick around get your
questions in the chat shoot the [__] you
can send me a message you can
you can ask a question and if you want
to venmo chat me I'll definitely bring
it up on the screen go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com venmo chat me now if you
want me to bring it up on screen I'll
put it in the uh I'll put it oh put it
in the chat one more time don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of Slim Jims
skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again years
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
thank you [__] em [__] em [__] em [__]
em [__] em [__] em we're back to the
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
just a little bit
if he had a question or comment throw it
in the chat I'll see if I can I can look
at it if you want me to see it for sure
go to the Ben mochenko to the Tony
michaels.com that's the tonymichaels.com
click the venmo Super Chat and get in
the venmo Super Chat and I'll bring that
up on screen as we shoot the [__] here
uh let's see what do we got here are you
guys excited about the mug shots
I I'm I mean we got John Eastman's this
morning uh mug shot let me see if I can
see if I can find that I think I think I
retweeted the mug shot so I had it handy
so I had it handy oh yeah here it is
here's his mug shot oh there's John
Eastman
oh [__]
can't make this [__] up uh so there's
John Eastman so we should have Rudy
Giuliani uh because Johnny Eastman
turned himself in yesterday and did you
see the video of him oh my God this
[__] guy
like do you believe do you still believe
Trump trump won yeah absolutely it was
stolen from him 100 percent
just because you say that
like just because you say that it was
that doesn't mean it's gonna be a good
legal defense you think you think
someone like John Eastman an attorney
would know that he apparently is not a
very good attorney
[Laughter]
oh [__] what do we got what do we got do
we got any questions in the chat here
uh for shoot the [__]
now let's see
did you see these freaks are fear Mark
yes I did
um Andy here on YouTube says speaking of
trucker Convoy that's one reason why I
played it because they're always they're
always doing these freakouts did you see
the freaks our fear-mongering about new
Kobe lockdowns yeah
um so so there's gonna be like the CDC
is because covet you know it's gonna be
winter here soon so the CDC is going to
give warnings like hey if you're sick or
you feel sick you should probably wear a
mask like that makes sense right it
doesn't matter if you have covet even if
you got a cough or if like you're
coughing heavy or if you're I don't know
contagious you should probably cover
your face when you're in public and
people who are who have autoimmune
disorders when you get into the season
of sickness if they don't want to get
sick because they're more vulnerable to
those types of sicknesses they should
probably wear a massive it protects them
it's not [__] complicated right but
they're talking about mandates and all
kinds of [__] and they're talking about
lockdowns now here's the lockdown thing
they're going to turn mark my [__]
words they're gonna shut down the
government next month I told you months
ago they were going to shut down the
government they're going to shut down
the government in September the House
Republicans are going to do this and
then the House Republicans are going to
be screaming about how the government
have lockdowns
and everyone's gonna have what lockdowns
yeah you can't go national parks you
can't do this you can't do that the
government has lockdowns for covert no
no no you shut it down
you shut it down so government shutdown
is going to try is going to try
to equate it to coven lockdowns that's
what they're going to try to do
and so they're gonna they're gonna try
to do the gas stove M Ms or gay queer
beer Bud Lights thing okay that's what
they're going to try to do we're gonna
shut down the government and then it's
going to be the government is locking
everything down
it's gonna be really dumb and the
problem is the [__] boneheads will
buy it
they'll buy it
the boneheads
we'll buy it
um yeah it's someone ran up flesh eating
bacteria there's like several cases holy
[__]
a flesh-eating bacteria
um and then I think I think in this was
it in the state of Washington
um like a milkshake Shack or something
like a like a diner
people died of Milkshakes I think
there's three people who died a
milkshakes because the milkshake
machines weren't clean it's almost like
it's almost like we should make sure
that counties County governments make
sure that
restaurants and stuff like
stick to health standards it's almost
like there's Health standards for a
reason or something I don't know
maybe there is yes uh care I don't know
excuse me someone on Twitch says
listeria
and in that is that from the um the
milkshakes
Lord yeah I was in Tacoma someone's
saying
holy actual [__]
holy [__]
can you imagine that
you think you think uh Lauren bobert
served listeria milkshakes
with her um with her diarrhea sliders
you remember that you remember that
story she went to like a festival and
they served pork sliders and it gave
everyone the shits whew
oh baby
um
uh Tony who's from DC is complaining he
doesn't have enough time to turn himself
in
are you talking about Mark Meadows
I mean listen I think the mark Meadows
thing is gonna yeah I told you the other
day that this Mark Meadows thing I don't
know how this is going like there could
be so many things
um that you could read into this this
drama with funny Willis and Mark Meadows
now Mark Meadows is trying as well as
two other defendants I believe there's
three trying to work this trial into a
federal courtroom number one Mark
Meadows wants to be separated from the
other group of 19. number one number two
Mark Meadows it seems or seems seemed or
seems to have a deal with the special
counsel Jack Smith to some degree
um now I am of the belief right now from
the evidence that you can gather from
this and the legal back and forth my
guess is
is that Mark Meadows
does not want to go to a Georgia State
Prison I mean who would want to
I think what happened or happening is
that he was
awarded some sort of immunity
or at least going to get a lesser
sentence with the federal court
if convicted of crimes related to I
don't know election fraud because he was
renting a house in a place that he
didn't live so he could vote someplace
right we know that
um and they didn't actually live there
they just rented some old broke ass
trailer in a trailer park or something
but also around the January 6. now he's
trying to make the case uh in court that
Bonnie Willis has no jurisdiction over
him because he was the chief of staff so
he appears to try to be tricking
um the courts into thinking that he has
executive privilege but it doesn't you
don't have executive privilege when
you're committing crime right
so I think the mark Meadows Saga is not
over and I think it's very interesting
and I think it's going to be key to how
these uh cases are going to turn out and
and and and be final right
of how integral Mark Meadows is and how
much he wants to protect his ass
because as we talked uh yesterday with
Texas Paul and I talked today before
about where Mark Meadows would want to
serve his prison time he definitely
would prefer to serve it in a federal
pen uh like a prison camp then a Georgia
State Penitentiary so that may be that
may be the chess move that Mark Meadows
is making but also I believe that this
tells the story to us and gives us
enough evidence to believe that funny
Willis is really not cooperating or
backing down because of Jack Smith I
think Bonnie Willis she's like [__] that
I'm not going to let the feds go first
we'll go at the same time which
it's not the case that the feds have to
go first right they don't ha or that
they are that they're superseding
of a case right because to be honest the
The Fulton County case the Fulton County
indictments against Trump and his allies
are very similar they they really
overlap with the DC case right they
overlap
there's a lot of overlap I mean one of
them is yesterday and I'm going to show
you a clip of John Eastman saying
absolutely no question did he think the
election was stolen which is [__]
wild [__]
wild stuff
that these people are still gonna go to
prison for Trump it's [__] insanity
well I mean what what could what could
you [__] possibly be thinking
but the other key to the mark Meadows is
Mark Meadows I believe it's yesterday or
day before
um requested an extension
of the time for him to self-surrender
to Fulton County and Bonnie Willis told
him to go [__] himself I mean she didn't
use those exact words but that's
basically what she told him you can go
[__] yourself
so and it appears that Mark Meadows does
not want to surrender to the Fulton
County authorities I think that's why
he's trying to move it into the feds too
so he can surrender at a federal
courthouse maybe I don't know
uh it's kind of weird what Mark Meadows
is doing because he's not making much
sense at this point uh if he is
cooperating with Jack Smith but it kind
of makes sense if he has some sort of
deal with Jack Smith so you know it's
kind of a double-edged sworder we won't
know exactly what's happening until
this happens but I I think Mark Meadows
is gonna make Bonnie Willis arrest him
I I honestly I think that's what Mark
Meadows is planning on doing here it
seems like that
seems like unless he shows up today
sometime to surrender because he's only
got till I think it's 12 30 Eastern time
on Friday
so noon 30
on Friday is what Mark Meadows has got
to show up because Bonnie Willis in her
letter said look I'll put a warrant out
for your rest and I will come get your
ass so I think Mark Meadows may make the
Fulton County
D.A put out a warrant for his arrest
and go get him I don't know it's
possible that Mark Meadows finally wants
to be part of the circus and be part of
the show so I don't know if that's who
you're talking about exactly but it's my
guess
maybe maybe
but who who wouldn't love to watch the
body cam footage of them going and
serving a an arrest warrant for Mark
Meadows who doesn't want that
ah
um someone asked about Jen Alice do I do
do we think Jen Ellis will take flight
no Jenna Alice Jenna Ellis is a scared
is scared she's terrified to be quite
honest with you she's terrified here
um and she's broke and Trump's not
paying anyone's bills but his own
so I think
I think I think that Jenna Ellis because
I think her bail was set at 100. when I
think Sydney Powell worked her bail down
to be a hundred uh I think Trump's the
only one with a uh his bail set at 200
at this point
um
but Jenna Ellis will buy she'll probably
be able to work up enough money to post
the bond
uh now rather she'll have enough money
to get a decent ass attorney who knows I
mean she's not a decent attorney so who
knows how her judgment is with attorneys
in the first place and she's not a very
good one anyways that's the reason why
she's in the situation that she's in
Good attorneys wouldn't represent Trump
period
that's that's what I'm telling you
at any point in Trump any part of
Trump's life if you were Trump's
attorney and you were representing him
you're probably not that great of an
attorney
that's why you probably are not an
attorney now most attorneys who have
represented Trump especially since he
became president aren't attorneys
anymore that's why so many of them
walked away I mean you've watched Ty
Cobb even that [__] Joker on TV
speaking out speaking out against Trump
because Ty Cobb didn't even appear to
appreciate uh representing Trump anyways
at least in hindsight
so Jenna Ellis is probably not going to
attract a decent attorney just because
she's not going to have the money and
who the [__] wants to be involved in
this if you're an attorney
because it's obvious that Donald Trump
convinces attorneys to commit crime with
him
because it really Giuliani and Johnny
was like I had the right I had the right
to advocate for my client on their
behalf yeah but you don't have the right
to commit crime with them
you don't have the right to join in a
conspiracy with them Jenna Ellis
Sydney Powell Rudy Giuliani John Eastman
Jeffrey Clark
cheeseburger the list goes on and on and
on here
right and every single one of these
attorneys is making the freedom of
speech and the right to counsel
listen you do have the right to counsel
in this country but you don't have the
right to commit a con criminal
conspiracy with an attorney that's not a
thing attorneys are not immune from
crime because they're an attorney okay
I'll give an example let's say an
attorney is representing a drug dealer
okay
and the drug dealer finally commences
the attorney you know what I can pay you
if we just do this one drug deal
together
now you're just gonna represent me as
counsel here you're not actually in the
drug deal right
but you know I'm doing the drug deal and
you're gonna do some things for me to
make sure the drug deal happens and that
way I can pay you
that's a conspiracy to commit crime the
attorney can't do that
that's not a [__] thing they can be
charged with crime even though the
attorney's like look all of our
conversations
all of our conversations commit crime is
protected by attorney-client privilege
no it's not
and we saw that with John Eastman and
Donald Trump
judge Carter a federal judge in
California not only said listen I'm
looking at these [__] emails and
they're you're in a conspiracy to commit
obstruction of an official proceeding
you're committing crime here so you're
not protected by the attorney-client
privilege there were some of those
emails that were afforded
attorney-client privilege but not all of
them so this [__] idea this idea from
John Eastman and I you know we got the
clips that he's what what did he say he
not just advocate
um
I forget the word the descriptive word
he used but advocacy is not the thing
he's thinking of he needs to go look up
the definition of advocacy
it is not the same as crime
oh this is going to be interesting week
it really is everyone thinks that the
debate's gonna be highly highly
interesting again the the only videos
that are going to be heavy punching is
when Chris Christie buries his his
[__] foot in in desantis's ass and
DeSantis doesn't have a good response
because DeSantis is a [__] weirdo
and he's only got canned responses and
he can't punch back worth a [__] because
he's a [__] ass [__]
the Santas
um someone bringing up the name Sandy
Woodward is that is that the attorney
that the employee number four said [__]
off is that it was Woodward right
and that the one sorry I'm looking for
the comment here
I want you guys to understand like when
I see the comments I see all the
comments together
so I see Facebook I see YouTube I see up
wires YouTube and I see the twitch
Channel all at once
so if I don't see your comments
sometimes it goes so fast I can't even
read it I can't read that well anyways
look at me look at me
I'm I'm from Missouri
where edumacation is real important now
they ban tons of books in Missouri so
yeah that's how it goes but someone
someone brought up uh the attorney's
name Woodward and I believe if they're
next if they've gonna lose their long
license I mean I I wouldn't I wouldn't
put it past
um any attorney that represents Donald
Trump at all oh here it is Stanley
that's what it was Stanley Woodward next
Alan on Facebook ask
you know I mean that's a good
possibility
that's a really good possibility
so
you know I'm not aware of exactly
um
what what Woodward's role
in getting employee number four to give
false testimony to a grand jury but I
would say that if Woodward had any
communication
well
bye
if there's any communication between
Woodward
and Trump or Trump team Trump about
getting uh employee number four in that
what it is is it play number four I
don't know Jesus Christ again how the
hell are we supposed to keep track
um
so that that Dad we're still shooting
the [__] if you got a question throw it
in the chat if you want to ask a
question again if you want to do a venmo
chat here's the QR code there on the
screen you can pause it there or you can
go to thetonymichaels.com that's the
Tony michaels.com you can throw venmo
chat on the venmo Super Chat I'll bring
it up here on the screen
oh what do you got here
yeah
everyone's saying yeah they're to the
next one
um
Brenda says isn't Woodward the one who
Jack is saying conflict of interest well
I mean I mean there's a lot of conflict
of interest with
um with Trump
and his attorneys because he hires these
people and they're representing several
people but I think the one you're
thinking about Brenda is for Walt NADA
and Carlos apparently they're they got
the same attorney there's conflict of
interest with the attorneys that Walt
NADA has hired now again
I want to give you an idea the federal
courts aren't aren't crazy about telling
you what attorney you can and can't have
I mean they they will if there is a
conflict of interest and they're not
quick to make you get an attorney that's
why the news that employee four told
um the Trump attorney that was hired for
him to kick rocks and hired the the
federal defender or ask the court to get
them a federal Defender is important and
the reason why that's important is
because it's likely
it's likely and that attorney might be
in trouble again if they coerce their
client into into giving false testimony
to the grand jury and they could be in
trouble here but uh here's the thing is
that the courts are very very slow to to
make you get an attorney what I mean by
that is like if you lose your attorney
like this employee number four is it
that they're not gonna get you an
attorney that fast the courts are like
well we'll kind of put your case and
your emotions and everything on hold
until you get representation like the
feds aren't in a hurry for anything
they're just not state courts a little
more of in a hurry that's why I keep
telling you that you're going to be
disappointed by chetkin at some point
she's going to make some rulings and do
some things that are going to piss you
off
they she just did she just is and the
reason why is because how federal courts
work and how a fair federal judge will
act and she will be fair she will be
fair she'll be straight down the line I
think I mean she's gonna be tough she's
not gonna go easy on this [__]
or any of these son of a [__] she
hasn't she hasn't gone easy on any of
the January sixth defendants yet but
she's Fair she's very fair she lets them
have their day in court she lets she
lets the discovery be known she gives
them enough time she is not unfair but
she is tough but again the unfair part
being fair is going to piss some people
off the anti-trump people
um but down in Florida or excuse me
Georgia Georgia Florida what are you
going to do uh Georgia it's going to be
different in that state court because
those judges are much more to speed to
trial if they can and the one reason why
is because there's [__] cameras in
the courtroom it's a circus
and they don't want their courtrooms to
become a circus but most of these judges
in these state courts and because of the
drama in state courtrooms they want the
transparency of the cameras they don't
want just the transcript to be read they
want what actually happened to be
recorded in the courtroom
um so it's just a different thing it's
just a different courtrooms different
laws now that's why
that's why Mark Meadows is trying to
it's trying to work his way into a
federal courtroom so there's not any
cameras
mainly
um Don here on YouTube says if Jeffrey
Clark the idiot phony Environmental
Lawyer grifter bought off Corporation
corporate is it bought off corporate
clown I mean our
he's a republican any Dawn well I mean
he's a Republican and he's a trump Ally
what what more could you say
it's very likely that John Eastman
Jeffrey Clark and Rudy Giuliani are
still on Trump's
[Music]
um
side as you want to say
because he has [__] on them he has dirt
on them
I don't know what kind I don't know what
he could possibly have over them but it
appears to be that way the same way that
he has it over Lindsey Graham
um
uh someone on YouTube says Tony do you
think Trump is going to be scared more
of his weight being made public
then his boy waltene will be out of his
sight for a few minutes well
I actually
um
I actually believe Trump does not want
to be weighed he didn't want his weight
but I know that
um
I I know
that Trump does not want a mug shot
that's what he does not want now he's
gone he's waffled back and forth on it
because if he gets a mug shot he wants
to be able to capitalize on it he wants
to make money on it
and that's not how it's gonna happen
so but we're probably going to get a mug
shot here tomorrow sometime late
tomorrow early Friday we'll have the
first public mug shot of Donald Trump
uh because of his 91 criminal counts
felony counts that he has against him
what else do we got here
any other questions if you got a
question again throw it in the chat
and we'll see we got a few more minutes
to do the shoot the [__] here and then
I'm gonna move on and we're gonna watch
some of these clips that I'm talking
about so you're not going to want to
miss us I don't know I don't think Gabe
Sanchez is going to be able to join us
today
um maybe maybe he might he might
see if he is
Evie's going to join us today I know
he's busy with the project that he's
working on so
um have I ever tried pick oh that's the
wrong one have I ever tried pickled beer
no I have not I've done pickle shots
you ever done pickle shots it just
tastes like pickled juice
I mean I like pickles but I don't just
sit and drink pickle juice out of a jar
so
but I have done pickle shots
um
do you you still believe Trump won't
ever go to prison
um uh I you know this is a good question
right and the reason why this is a good
question is because I do think he's
going to be convicted
in each one of these jurisdictions maybe
not on every single count but he
definitely he definitely will catch
convictions in Manhattan uh in Miami in
DC and in Georgia it's possible we could
see something out of Arizona
um Michigan Pennsylvania Wisconsin we'll
see we'll see if those states can bring
cases against him the way that Georgia
has with their laws because each state
is different with the laws and the you
know the criminal code so we'll see if
they can bring cases against Trump in
those States but in the four
jurisdictions that they're in now I
believe he will be convicted to some
degree maybe not of every single one of
the counts but the majority of them
I mean can you imagine this guy's gonna
have you know more than 50 he's going to
be convicted on more than 50 felonies
probably
more than likely at least half because
we're going to get more we're going to
get more felony Counts from superseding
indictments because he can't stop
criming he's still criming like he's
still climbing in this moment he's
probably obstructing justice he's
probably gonna have witness tampering
he's gonna have all kinds of [__]
charges against him by the time it's all
over with
but the question of rather he goes to
prison is a different question than is
he convicted right that's a different
question
because the feds are going to are going
to sentence him
and the state Manhattan the state of New
York will sentence him and Georgia now
if he's sentenced carnival at the same
time right if he's convicted in sentence
depending on if they let him out on
appeals which the feds are likely to let
him out on appeals the states maybe not
so much
um but depending on the timing of all
all of it
and how quickly they get to a trial and
how quickly they get to a jury because
jury selection is likely to last a long
time like in Georgia because there's so
many defendants
but once we get to those moments right
I don't know how they incarcerate him
like I I don't have a good guess
I mean you would want them just to throw
him in a prison like everyone else
so and me and Texas Paul kind of talked
about this yesterday about the Secret
Service and how you jail a former
president right so because we've never
done this before because we've never
elected a [__] such a goddamn buffoon
criminal before
so it's a good question rather
um he'll go to a prison maybe not two
prison but a prison because Bop the
Bureau of Prisons is responsible for
incarcerating a convicted Federal
criminals right and Bop can basically
dictate how they want to incarcerate
them if the judge doesn't give
instruction
so if the judge doesn't give instruction
on how to incarcerate bop is kind of the
the agency that's going to decide
um where and how that person serves
their sentence so it's the Bop could say
you know what we can't put him in a
federal facility it's just not feasible
we don't have a way to keep him safe in
a federal facility that's a possibility
that they come to that conclusion and
the Bop decides to detain him on one of
his properties that he still has left
I don't know
I don't know what that looks like you
know the most important thing is we had
an election to win
we got an election to win
like he's gonna be the nominee I don't
know if you know that I mean in the
lead-up to this because that's what
they're really looking for tonight in
this debate
and I'm not gonna watch the whole debate
because I got [__] karaoke I got
better [__] to do than watch a bunch of
half-assed Nazis stand on stage trying
to out not to each other I really I
ain't got to I watched the Calypso we'll
go over it tomorrow okay and I'll tell
you my analysis of the clips because I'm
gonna show you because that's all that
matters anyways in today's world
is the clips of what the overall content
is what the feeling on the internet webs
are
but uh the question do I still do I
think Trump will go to prison
it is a great question it is a question
that will we will ask ourselves for many
years because even if he gets convicted
and they do this or they do that I mean
what what
what does it mean to be incarcerated in
a federal prison what does it mean to be
incarcerated
in a Georgia State Prison or or a a
prison in New York
so these are all questions but we should
ask those questions much later
much later
let's see what else do we got here we
got a few more minutes before we go to a
break I'm gonna go to a break at the top
of the hour
um and I'm still waiting to see if Gabe
Sanchez is going to join us
um uh to go through some of these clips
I got some clips I want to go with you
I'll go over with you uh Jeffrey asks
will he flee no he's not gonna flee
heated on fled
took off if he was gonna flee yeah he
can't go anywhere anyways I mean Russia
is not a good option at this point
um for him he's likely to be exiled in
Russia in a way that he doesn't want to
be exiled he won't be he won't be the
king like he is of his cult here there
because he doesn't have a cult there
um and Putin has a cult there not not
Trump so it won't be the same
[Music]
um
so I don't think he's gonna flee and
again the only place that he could flee
is Russia and that's not it's not going
to work now crystal says how about Saudi
Arabia on on Facebook there I you know
maybe but I I doubt it because he's not
going to be he's not going to be the
[__] cult leader in Saudi Arabia
either that he is here see that's the
thing that's the thing that Donald Trump
really that he got addicted to right he
didn't really run and come down the
golden escalator and you know dehumanize
uh people coming across the border brown
people because he wanted to be president
it was all publicity stunt
and it turned out people really liked
his publicity stunt a bunch of [__]
toothless rednecks bought his bigotry
and he discovered in that process that
oh I could be I could be a cult leader
so that's how it culminated it really
wasn't intentional anything that Trump
does well isn't intentional he [__]
Falls ass backwards into it
right
it when he tries to intend to do
something it turns to liquid [__] every
time
[__] and just look at Trump water and
Trump stakes and Trump University so
when you're doing that sound happens so
I appreciate you guys
doing uh shoot the [__] with me
shooting the [__] today we're gonna go
to a quick break when we come back we're
gonna watch these clips don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show do you want
your very own pardon blanket
do you because they exist for real now
the Barton blankets are real I'm not
sure it's a real thing go to the Tony
michaels.com
stand down and go to Gabe Sanchez's
merch store click on the link there
it'll guide you through to his merch
store through his link tree that's right
the pardon blanket exists it's a real
thing if you want one go to
thetonymichaels.com scan down and go to
Gabe's merch store it'll direct you
through linktree
to get you to his merch store and get
you your very own pardon blanket
pardon blankets are real they weren't
real for a long time but they are real
now so go to the Tony michaels.com click
on Gabe Sanchez's merch store link it'll
guide you through his link tree to get
your very own pardon blanket and I know
I know you guys are sad that Gabe
Sanchez isn't going to be here today I
know you're really sad about that
it's just a shame that he showed up
shame
I literally have mine down to like the
third bar right because these in-ear
monitors are so strong right well and
the other thing is when I play Clips
they got to be really loud for the
audience here so a lot of times like my
ears are ringing that's that's why I
have the over the yeah that's probably
not like long term a good solution you
should it's probably not we probably
should fix something else huh what'd you
say what was that what what sorry what
what was that what what yeah is that why
you called the show that because you're
deaf now because yeah well it's not so
much that I'm deaf from the inner
monitors it's that I am Deaf from the
victim blaming in victimhood and the uh
uh you know it's like Donald Trump today
where he posted a uh untruth social and
he said I will proudly
surrender in Georgia proud oh [__] give
me a get the [__] out of here probably
mildly well I've got a video and I think
you're talking about mayor mugshot uh I
think it was skip on Discord he said
that that should be his nickname from
now on it is a great nickname mayor
mugshot because he's bitching this
morning uh Samantha here on YouTube I
want to point this out she said I'm a
trickster so they thought they really
thought you weren't coming in I I didn't
know for sure I know you've been busy
with the project so I wasn't yeah yeah
sure exactly if you were gonna if you
were gonna make it in but this morning
hahaha
that that hasn't I've been I've been
[__] tracking to see when this photo
goes live by the way which one
for Rudy Rudy he's the he's the main one
today so you see you think you think the
Rudy uh mug shot is gonna be better than
the Eastman or the cheese burrow or the
Donald Trump what do you think which one
do you think
there's a part of me right now that has
this idea and I don't think I can
implement it in time because I got two
well who knows we'll see I basically
have
um no I don't want to say I don't want
to say it online because I'm afraid
someone's gonna take it yeah they'll
steal it yeah there's plenty of people
here that are watching this show to
steal content trust me I say [__] two
months ago and then msnbc's like well we
should probably say what Tony's saying
we should probably just say that now
this morning they were like they were
like oh Chris Christie is the perfect
wedge for the Republican primary I'm
like Jesus Christ you mother
ways so what's this idea oh you can't
say the idea no I can't say it I can't
say the idea because why do Jesus just
know it requires me collecting all of
the mug shots
oh yeah and no it's not trading cards
you even though that is an idea that I
was I was I would literally I was out on
a date with my partner last night and
we're having tacos because it's Taco
Tuesday and there's this new spot that
we wanted to try yeah uh how were the
tacos pretty good pretty good what'd you
get what'd you get I don't mean to get
sidetracked here yeah this is this is
important they were these it's actually
it's a Michelin uh star rated Taco spot
they used to have God damn yeah I know I
I didn't know about it and then they
just got a a brick were they expensive
or no for like 14.50 they were three it
was a trio for these like specialty two
off menu items and then you get to
choose which one's in the trio or is it
like a trio or the same like this is the
trio so one was chorizo and yeah it was
another one was uh carne asada and
another one was chicken but the base had
uh Frijoles on them and then but in
addition to that it was
um they throw the tortillon and then
they throw cheese on melted crispy and
then that's the base damn so like three
of those on its own perfect would I go
there for like a late night late night
bite to get those tacos no but they do
have other street tacos I guess I'm I'm
a guy who's like if it's late night I'm
like oh my [__] craving tacos I would
just go to the [__] bender on the
street at night he's drunk late night
are he's already stoned
and I'll go down four o'clock in the
afternoon he's stoned he's like hey I
gotta go get some Street tacosa give me
some tacos whatever man oh man anyway we
were there last night and we were
talking and then all of a sudden I got
this notification I think because I saw
Scott McFarland had posted Eastman's
photo and I was like oh [__] yeah oh
here's the first one of the batch and I
was thinking about this idea last night
which is one and the second one I won't
bring up but one was
um
the trading cards right because we
everyone had made trading cards for all
of the like uh FBI's Most Wanted and
then I think there's even been ones that
were one that were made around like
Trump's kind of group but this one well
you could just you know print off new
playing cards
um I have another idea that maybe I'll
be able to implement bef like as a
Friday by Friday when I have the full
list
of 19
defendants
ah okay so it's like the brain is
I'm trying to get I've got it I've got
an idea for Rudy specifically I got an
idea for Trump specifically and then I
got an idea for all of them together and
can't you well here is Rudy this morning
oh man [__] wine fist victims he's
speaking this morning fluently oh my God
it's [__] pathetic I'm America's
mayor no you were you were you wrong
this is him outside of his his little uh
condo
home thing where he's trying his
Penthouse that he's trying to sell for
like six and a half million dollars
which again is him that that he he
values
and they've listed it for six and a half
however
he's not gonna get six and a half no no
well listen to him whine and [__] about
this he's gonna be whining [__] you
ain't getting the money for his hat for
his [__] Penthouse listen
Georgia and I'm feeling very very good
about it because I feel like I'm
defending the rights of all Americans
he he's doing really good about getting
arrested this morning look this is such
[__] bone-headedry okay Rudy Giuliani
knows what's gonna happen he he has been
a prosecutor before he knows what's
gonna happen they're going to detain him
they're going to arrest him they're
going to process him they're gonna
probably bring him into a court to
arraign him if there is a judge
available to arraign him if there's not
they will just book him and let him go
on Bond and he will come back for an
arraignment it's really [__] [__] I
wonder how much because you typically
put like a a percentage down for a bond
right well if you're using if you're
using a bondsman yeah but I mean I mean
you could you could just put uh cash
down if you've got it but Rudy doesn't
have it right so that's what I wonder
you know what money is he putting down
well what's what's his bond is his bond
a hundred I think it's 100 I know Sydney
Powell negotiations
100 so I'm assuming Rudy Giuliani is
also 100 let me just confirm so in a lot
of states and I know in the state of
Missouri a lot of The Bondsmen they take
10 percent uh to do a bond for you
through through a through a bond agency
um and they take 10 so if it's if it's a
hundred grand for the bond then likely
and I don't know if Georgia is the same
but
um 10 is usually the cost of the bond
from the bondsman
but can you imagine I don't know you
know there's so many memes of Marjorie
Taylor green
um as Dog the Bounty Hunter Dog the
Bounty Hunter is Margarita and margin
Tater green is in Georgia so if like
there was a world where Marjorie Taylor
green and Dog the Bounty Hunter are the
same person like they are the same
person then it could be conceivable that
Marjorie Taylor green As Dog the Bounty
Hunter could give Rudy Giuliani a bond
yeah the bond out of Georgia okay it
looks like it has not been announced yet
however Misty Hampton has a bond for 10K
I mean she's the she's the smallest one
on the batch even though she did try to
[__] intimidate and threaten
um but she's she said at 10K it I don't
think it's been announced yet what he
what his bond is but people are guessing
anywhere from a hundred thousand to a
hundred and fifty thousand right and
again I think Sydney Powell negotiated
hers down to 100 and Jenna Ellis is 100
Jen Ellis probably can't afford a
hundred thousand dollar bond to be quiet
no well so a lot of decision money she
she just passed a hundred thousand
dollars yesterday and with regards to
her uh gifts and go but what I want
people to know is that the gifts and
goat doesn't go to Jenna the Gibson go
goes specifically to the lawyer
so the lawyer the lawyer I think people
are like oh no she got her a hundred
thousand dollars for the bond no no
that's not how it works first off that's
not how it works and two that money is
specifically to cover the legal expenses
for her lawyer because they're gonna
have to obviously be have you know
representation in court and litigate and
all that stuff and that's a lot of time
I don't know how much her lawyer you
know charges per hour but
you've probably got a team that's
already been working and as well as
Associates that are trying to get all
the documents to prove that Jenna Ellis
didn't actually
say these things because she knew they
were lies which because she wholly
believed them and on the on the uh on
the topic of Rudy Giuliani I don't know
if you saw this but Rudy Giuliani even
though
even though he's one of the 19
defendants and he's nearly broke both
financially and emotionally emotionally
but also uh reputationally like bankrupt
there's another thing that just came out
recently where he was on a he was on a
talk show like a radio show and took a
question from a caller and said that he
has scientific evidence
that the 2020 election like DNA
I guess so I I don't know he doesn't but
he doesn't say what it is but he said
just this past week he said I have
scientific evidence that the 2020
election was rigged and that Donald
Trump won even after all this stuff
happened he said like you know what
I'm gonna fight this one trying to keep
fighting this one scientific um Fenn
here on YouTube says morally bankrupt
that's right he is morally Brinker he's
been morally bankrupt for a while even
before he met Donald Trump but because
of Donald Trump he is financially and
also reputationally bankrupt
and guess what I'm doing it what was
that on Rudy Giuliani and this was the
final touch that I needed just for him
to be arraigned I'm just waiting for
that mug shot
here is Ernie Giuliani displaying his
reputational bankruptcy right here
as I did so many times as a United
States Attorney
people people like to say I'm different
I'm the same Rudy Giuliani no no you're
not New York City
the safest city in America
describe more than any mayor in the
history of any City anywhere and I'm
fighting for justice I have been from
the first moment I represented Donald
Trump and it's a map
who has now been proven several times no
no you defended a rapist he has to be
proven innocent
they have to be proven to be Liars
actually
enemies of our Republic
destroying my right to counsel my right
to be a lawyer his right to counsel no
you did that Rooney died at all as
lawyers never heard of that before
America yeah we've never heard of that
before because not so many lawyers have
crimed with the president of the United
States before you [__] idiot listen
this victim means [__] that he's got
going on I think it's beautiful wow Rudy
you couldn't be doing a better job than
ruining ruining your legacy keep going
my friend yeah I love I love this whole
this whole karmic twist this karmic
irony that the people who are literally
having the last laugh right now I mean
outside of us but the people who are
really having the last left are the
[__] Mobsters that he put away
because of Rico well there are they're
already out there are already yeah yeah
most of them are out of prison and
they're [__] laughing at him watching
TV watching this guy go down for real
the best the best part about it is that
so many if not all of these people
because uh according to one of I think
Rickman the lawyer who represents a lot
of these people dirt from these Rico
cases that Rudy put away a lot of these
guys are Trump supporters and they
[__] hate Rudy's guts right and even
the lawyer was like you could quote me
on that [__]
he didn't say [__] but he said you can
quote me on that they are you know so
happy that Rudy is [__] well speaking
of being [__] there's another another
one of these defendants in the Georgia
case that's flailing uh Enterprise yes
and trying not to surrender
um by Friday at 12 30.
he wants an extension he what he thinks
he's in time well he doesn't he doesn't
only want an extension he's trying to
fight the ability and put up a
restraining order for them to arrest him
right well he's trying to work this case
into a federal courtroom
um and I think Mark Meadows wants it in
a federal courtroom so there's not
cameras
to be quite honest I think that but I
don't know I don't know what the deal is
that he's got with Jack Smith if he has
a deal I don't know if Bonnie Willis is
telling Jack Smith I don't give a [__]
if you got a deal with Mark Meadows I'm
charging that [__] I don't know
what it is but this letter makes it
clear about Mark Meadows uh surrendering
on Friday this is from the D.A down in
Fulton County it says good morning Mr
Moran which is Mark bento's attorney I
am not granting any extensions I gave
two weeks for people to surrender
themselves to the court your client is
no different than any other criminal
defendant in this jurisdiction
the two weeks was a tremendous courtesy
at 12 30 p.m on Friday I shall file
warrants in the system my team has the
availability of me to discuss reasonable
consent bonds
Wednesday and Thursday
yours in service finding D Willis she
forgot to [__] him here I don't know
where that it was supposed to be in
there somewhere but she got it well I
think I think the F and and funny stands
that might be yeah right [__] T
Willis
she does not give a single flying [__]
no if Mark she's like look man I gave
you all [__] two weeks I went on TV I
didn't make it a secret I said here are
the warrants this is who or these are
the people that need to come in you can
voluntarily come in and if you don't
then I'm issuing a warrant for your
arrest and if you want to fight it and
you want to come in handcuffs in the
back of a [__] squad car because you
were too much of a [__] ass [__] and
decided that you didn't want to comply
because you were some alpha male
[__] cuck
then fine that's the path that you take
but guess what you're coming and I'm
arraigning you one way or another
whether you come in handcuffs or you
decide to come involuntarily either way
I decide I'm Gonna Come
yeah I'm gonna come that's Donald Trump
he's like I'm gonna come down to Georgia
because I am a real Patriot and I am
doing this for you yeah same same
narrative same messaging of they're not
coming after me they're coming after you
no Donald you broke the law as well as
all of your other coup plotters in
addition to that when he says oh there
you know I'm just they're they're coming
after you and I'm standing in the way
okay again that's called obstruction if
you want more charges
sure we can add those we can tack them
on if you want but at the end of the day
you're the actual criminal here and the
fact that you're trying to restructure
this idea and reform it as oh no no guys
guys they're coming after you but I'm
laying down on the line on behalf of you
which is the same thing he's doing now
which he said I will proudly be arrested
in Georgia it's like Donald Trump being
like I got covered for you it's like
right you got it yeah because you're a
[__] dumbass right well um speaking
of dumbass John Eastman
um we know we we saw his mug shot
earlier but we didn't show the video of
him outside the courthouse or outside
the jail I should say it's actually the
jail that they have to surrender to
which is even better and it's [__]
awesome anyways John Eastman uh decides
outside the jail that he's he still
believes that the election was stolen
let's listen
it represents a crossing of the Rubicon
for our country implicating the
fundamental First Amendment right to
petition the government for redress of
grievances
as troubling it targets attorneys for
their zealous advocacy on behalf of
their clients
um I think you you're using that word
advocacy and I don't think you what how
does it go on princess you use that word
but I don't think you use that word that
means what you think it means advocacy
keep using that word
I don't think you mean it means what you
don't think it means yeah I'm not sure
the the exact uh phrasing I haven't I I
I usually maybe you should put that in a
what was that I'm just yeah
I don't think it means uh I I think I
feel like that line could be used for
anything that they said well I mean
really honestly with like any
mongoloidite out there any of them yeah
like all the way up execution it's like
I don't think
you need to get addiction that's the old
dictionary I'm gonna look up that word I
but I I have a I have a theory here and
I don't know how actual actually because
again I'm not a lawyer but I don't know
how plausible this is in the courtroom
uh
but I believe
that the only path forward that these
people can take
is not admitting that they knew they
were lying so what you're saying is like
plausible deniability yeah I think they
have to say because you could say like
look the facts right here A B C D E all
the way to Z the election was not rigged
it was not stolen these were all you
know uh falsified affidavits these you
know whatever and on their end they
could come out and say no no I truly
believe that this election was stolen
Donald Trump won and that the that the
people were telling the truth and I had
I had no ability to not
agree to them and that's that's an
interesting point and I think that's the
only path forward because if they admit
guilt then they if they go in saying
okay yeah we knew we lost lied we lied
we knew it we were just that's all part
of this team it's a guaranteed 100 uh
guilt okay so so this is interesting and
the reason why this is interesting is
because I was trying to find a way
because I watched the uh depth herd debt
be heard on Netflix last night yeah yeah
oh how was that so I it's pretty good
and I was trying I was trying to figure
out a way that I was going to work that
into there you go into the commentary
and this is very interesting because
um there is parts of that trial where
Amber Heard does a lot of different
things that she shouldn't have done
um one of those things I believe when
you watch the documentary because what
they do is unique in the documentary is
they tell both sides of the trial at the
same time right which is not how it not
not how it played out in real life it
was her part and then his part right and
they were totally separate right so they
weren't side by side which is kind of
unique it makes it very interesting to
see the the testimony uh side by side
well one on top of the other like it
happened you know in real time in both
testifying but I think there was a few
moments because let's face it if you
watch the documentary you will know that
those two Amber Heard and Johnny Depp
are both [__] [__] right they're
just they're just they're [__] now
you could you could make cases of why
one is more of a [__] than the other
but it's really obvious that in that
courtroom Amber Heard
was not only lying about what she lied
about but she was really doing stupid
things to try to do that one of the
things
um and not to spoil it is she brings up
someone's name when she really shouldn't
have and if anyone was following those
cases you might know what I'm talking
about but it explains it but there's one
thing that she does
when I was watching it and I was stoned
when I was watching it so I was really I
was focused in on it right but there's
one thing that she kept doing that it
felt like her attorneys was telling her
to do but it wasn't working like it
wasn't it wasn't trying to cry well that
but she would turn to the jury and
everything she would say she would turn
and tell them and talk to them which
there's a moment when you're probably
testifying which it is a good thing and
Johnny Depp turned towards them a couple
times when he was like addressing them
yeah but when he wasn't when he was
addressing the court he was turned
towards the court but she kept turning
towards them to get sympathy
and and she was caught in lies while she
was doing that and I think if their if
their strategy okay if their strategy in
open court especially in Georgia where
there's going to be cameras yeah is to
try to continue something that they know
is a [__] lie and an open court they
continue to do this thing to pretend
that this lie is the truth that Trump
won and it was stolen from him and [__]
it is going to be very bad for them when
the jury sees them doing that just like
it was horrible for Amber Heard when she
was doing that because I don't think
everything Amber Heard said was a lie
some of it was some of it wasn't but
because she kept doing the same thing
when she was telling the truth and
telling lies we believed that it was all
lies right yeah and it's gonna be the
same [__] thing like at some
point in this trial the jury's gonna go
you [__] knew you knew everyone
but you [__] that are sitting
here we're saying that [__] Trump
lost Only You bastards Only You bastards
that are caught up in this case were
continued to believe that he had law are
one right stolen only you [__]
so when that happens the jury is not
only going to discredit that idea that
they still [__] believe you know just
because they believe it's true and it's
true which is insanity it's not a legal
argument or not a very good one at that
no I know but that's the only path they
have going forward even even though
uh Farney Willis and the rest of her
team are going to prove
you know wholeheartedly I know that
everyone is innocent until they're
proven guilty I get that but when you
know the [__] smoke
there's fire and if you've been indicted
four separate times that really you know
like the hackers that took over Donald
Trump's Patriot legal defense fund
website
if you if this keeps happening to
someone then you have to question like
is it really everyone against one person
or is it this one person and they're
morally corrupt and they're doing these
things that are illegal and it really
does prove that they are guilty because
it's not like everyone you might be like
um okay two you're like I don't think
it's a coincidence anymore but when
you're up to four
you're you're kind of like okay this
this is okay no there's something else
here and in court they're gonna try to
play like no we believe 100 the election
was stolen we have this evidence Rudy
Giuliani that's the problem is that's
the problem is they're not I like
they're going to be proven wrong wow
right but it's likely that the judge the
judge probably won't even allow the
their evidence in court to be presented
as evidence of why they believe and the
reason why is because it's presidential
number one but number two there's
there's no reason for a judge to submit
evidence that's not actual evidence yeah
there's no reason for them but but I
think you're right they're going to
continue this charade uh until the chips
start to fall right and because I I
believe at some point
um some of these people are going to go
and you know with their tail between the
leg and really seek some sort of [__]
deal where they don't have to spend as
much time in a Georgia State Prison but
here's John Eastman getting into his car
yesterday in Atlanta uh and continuing
this this [__] ridiculous lie but
won't launch
that's from about the 2020 election
watch some of our Exchange
do you still think the election was
stolen absolutely absolutely still no
question
I love how she's like do you still think
the election was stolen
um
really
well let me play it again I love how she
asked this question watch her face watch
watch how she asks
do you still think the election was
stolen do you think absolutely still no
question no it's like it's like when
you're really gonna you're really gonna
go with that one you're still good
you're still going with that one huh
right it's like when a mom walks in the
living room the lamps [__] shattered
all over the floor it was a dog and it's
right you're really gonna go with that
one really think the dog did it do you
really do you that I believe that you
all did it do you really really do you
think I was born yesterday I love when
my mom whenever my brother and I would
get into trouble she'd be like do you
think I was born yesterday right do you
really do you really think that you
think I'm gonna believe you about how
this happened uh so that's uh that's how
that's going
um down in um but apparently there's
people showing up
um you know at these um
oh God damn it one I'm just showing
people showing up in support what the
hell is this by the way let me tell you
something listen this this I just got
over this image
I saw it yesterday and I just got over
it did Patriot takes post this I think
to actually post this I think let me
tell you something this is not that bad
of a rendition of Donald Trump yeah I
mean look at that [__] little chin
that orange chin that he was like
so so complaining about like the
ballooned the balloon turkey neck I mean
it's pretty good rendition I'm just
gonna say it's just so uh the support
there woo baby
it's big support I'm telling you
it's huge
also yeah the reason that Donald Trump
is having his arraignment tomorrow yeah
it's because one one
he's a [__] ass [__] right and if he
really okay I just want to put this out
there if he really was a [__] Alpha
like everyone else in Maga says that he
is then he would not comply he'd go no
no no no no I'm not going down to
Georgia come get me [__] you coming
because here's the thing if he really
was smart about this I guarantee he
could milk the [__] out of getting
arrested and saying that he was a victim
right political persecution they put
they put your favorite former president
under arrest they put me in handcuffs I
don't know why you didn't do that come
just do not comply
and he's going to go on Thursday but
he's going to go during the debates that
are happening in Milwaukee
because of course he doesn't want to
show up
and get dragged during the debates and
get owned
and so his his you know uh attempt is
well if I can compete with the media
coverage right and get arraigned because
then I can make it all about me right
well that's and that's really because
his strategy here because he's terrified
of Chris Christie that's the reason why
he's not going to go on to the debates
is because he knows Chris Christie will
[__] work him up one side and down
the other and he knows Chris Christie's
going to do that even with him not being
there now the one thing Donald Trump
does does know and the strategy is
actually a good strategy if you want to
know the honest truth for him not going
and the reason why is because Chris
Christie is going to beat the ever
loving [__] out of Ron DeSantis at this
debate and basically Chris Christie is
going to be responsible for taking out
Ron DeSantis here um which is gonna is
gonna give Trump more breathing room
because it's likely to put vivec in the
second place category which is exactly
what Trump wants that's exactly what
Vivek is there to do is to be his number
two so he can say oh the only one really
that can beat me is Vivek and vet can
say Well I'm don't actually want to beat
you because I'm a plant and I say stupid
[__] about 911 and I try to sound smart
but I'm not really smart I'm I'm
actually a sort of Scholars recipient I
and that's how they're going to attack
me once once the the primary start
what's going to happen is everyone's
gonna call Vivek isaurus back candidate
that's what they're gonna do
um Also if anyone wants to call them
other names you should look into his
history because his former company used
to deal with China and he's very
anti-china on prices right now well it's
always it's always with this [__] guy
and again that's why Vivek is a plant
but I have a feeling I have a feeling
he's going to show up on Friday or well
I guess he can't show up because he's
during the debate I was thinking that
vivec would always because he oh no no
no no the debates tonight Trump's going
to turn himself in tomorrow so Vivek is
totally going to go to Georgia oh yeah
yeah oh yeah he's going to write a
letter to the D.A demanding demanding
that she dropped the charges on Donald
Trump because he likes the taste of
Donald Trump's balls or something I
don't know I mean some of the people I
just want to say some of the people in
the debate I've never even heard of
I Larry Elder he's out in your neck of
the woods he's mad he's not at the
debate apparently well you know he also
made it I saw uh I saw yesterday he made
a claim that the polls that Donald Trump
is owned or is backed by Trump and it's
like oh okay that's a very interesting
thing to say [__] out of here listen
again folks if you're listening to
anyone who is quoting polls
you're like 20 years behind the the
times okay pulls her [__] they're
absolute garbage do not listen to them
and if they make you feel good fine but
that's all they're supposed to do is
make you feel good and it's supposed to
conduct narrative do you really believe
that Trump is 40 points ahead no he's
not 40 points ahead those [__] those
[__] polls are all rigged it's to
make the appearance of him being ahead
and I keep telling you this that that's
all that matters to Republicans they
don't give a [__] about the truth just
listen to this [__] just listen
to this [__] that that flew down
to Mar-A-Lago to lick Donald Trump's
balls so he could be Speaker of the
House listen to this [__] projection
nonsense listen they can fight us and
Larry I've never seen an Administration
use different form of government like
this to withhold information since the
Nixon Administration what is appalling
what they're doing I've never seen a
person in elected office use their
office like this to have 20 shell
people in the family getting paid like
Donald Trump do you take certain actions
what the [__] that's like literally
literally what the Trump family did yeah
okay how many I want to let's talk about
I think it was like over 500 through
companies you mean shell yeah AKA shell
companies that Donald Trump used when
they were trying to move money to
another spot to another spot to another
spot to another spot I mean the fact
they've got 500 of these companies that
are out there passing money from one to
the other they have to trace back that
they identified during the Trump
organization
right do you know what's crazy they were
charged and convicted the Trump Board of
17 felony counts they had to pay a
million dollars for this for fountains
and his orange Mussolini Jesus the guy
who made him speaker in the house
because he genuinely liked to do him
is charged with personal felonies in
Manhattan for doing exactly what he's
describing this is [__] Bonkers ass
[__] it's Bonkers it doesn't make sense
but you're like Tony what why is Trump
40 points ahead because it's all
[__] everything they say is a
hundred percent horse [__] it's
horseshit because I guarantee you if the
polls were rigged and Chris Christie's
favor Donald Trump would be
d-o-n-e done done done done but they're
not rigged in [__] Chris Christie's
favor they're rigged in Donald Trump's
favor folks because Republicans the
quiet thing that they don't want to say
is that they truly really 100 love him
they love him because they let him be
the worst version of themselves
he gives him permission just like he
gives Kevin McCarthy to say wild ass
crazy [__] about Biden that Trump
actually did wild stuff but you know
these Republicans are wild you know I
thought this Republican was dead
I really did Newt gingers is not dead
that's the news here to me in this clip
I thought new kingers is dead man are
you serious this guy's still alive you
mean the adulterer right well that's
what we're talking about right we're
talking about the man who who has
different life right now didn't didn't
his wife get cancer and he's like [__]
you can't cancer ridden life I'm gonna
go run off with my next wife yeah can
you do that he's that scumbag that's why
I'm surprised that he's still alive I'm
I you know I'm surprised there's not
like a Newt Gingrich got murdered
Netflix series who knows there could be
there
his new wife is well he's had three
wives actually uh but his new one like
someone else like so it must yeah it
must be a prerequisite of being a a
leader of the Republican Party The Party
of them liberal majority okay hold on
just show this photo all right show this
photo because I honestly from afar I
looked at it
Tyron says breaking new gingers is not
dead uh Ty you should probably write
that story publish it somewhere I
I thought yeah
what is this
where's this link
this is his wife
this is which one his current one right
okay so what what about it what what am
I supposed to be seeing here I looked at
the witch so I was like on the Wikipedia
and I was like oh my God this looks like
it's been like this looks like it's got
a Photoshop filter to it and then I open
up the full version and I was like this
doesn't look real like this looks like
AI generated this photo is it really
this is real this is her photo
that's a real photo
yeah well
I don't know I honestly looked at it I
was like no this is like a this is like
a a like a like do you think anything do
you think Wikipedia will start doing
that you say Ida
to generate some of its content because
remember it's based on you know it's
based on actual facts yeah yeah right
and Wikipedia is so accurate right well
I mean are we saying that I didn't I
didn't say that are you saying
um
I'm saying there's a lot of facts in it
I'm not saying it's all factual well I
mean they have a lot of people that are
I mean you know speaking of Wikipedia
actually does wait does Wikipedia say
that Newt gingers is still alive
oh you know what or is this an AI
generated let me check Android on Sean
Hannity
[Music]
hold up on the story he was born in
1943. in Harrisburg Pennsylvania and
he is still alive his name was Newton
Leroy Leroy McPherson whoa whoa whoa
whoa what
wait a second
Newt Gingrich is not Newt Gingrich no
he's not new McPherson full name is he
changes names like he changes wives well
this is it looks like this is why so
he's got a relative okay I'm not
believing that the Newt gingers we're
talking about is still alive if this is
this might be a different [__]
McPherson because his biological okay so
his body his his mother was Kathleen
Kitt
um
and then his father biological father
was Newton
serial series
I could be I don't know the name I don't
know uh McPherson
um
uh and his mother married Robert
Gingrich that's why he changed oh I see
so it's a step name yes yes okay well
maybe but it might be because Robert
Gingrich was a career army officer who
sir who served tours in Korea oh so he
wants that to be his dad yeah ice okay
yeah it makes sense that makes sense you
[__] lying scumbag okay well let's
listen to how he responds to Biden I'm
serious
he this is him responding folks to Biden
petting a dog I'm not [__] you this
is the response he gave to Biden petting
a dog let's listen seriously
look I I think
this visit to Maui
frankly is just plain frightening
well how can you have a
commander-in-chief who is totally out of
touch with reality who makes up a story
which is a lie who has no understanding
of the scale of the disaster which has
occurred who has uh literally now has no
empathy for the human beings around him
oh my God this is in response to Jill
Biden petting a dog now you know why why
do you know why dogs they hate dogs well
no I'm saying like do you know why he
went up to the dog do you know what the
dog is for
it's a search and rescue dog yeah search
and rescue now like for bodies and also
in Hawaii it's hot okay it's a hot
[__] when you get down towards
the equator right here yeah it's crazy a
hot [__] like the other the
clothes and you know apparently the
closer you get to the Equator the hotter
it [__] gets well the other part of
it too is that it's not okay so he said
I believe the quote is uh hot ground
is what is what Biden said for anyone
for anyone who owns dogs you all know
well you put boots on them is what you
put boots yeah so I've got little boots
for my dogs when we take them out when
it's [__] hot outside because their
paws are so sensitive but what if you
what if they don't have boots on then
one
well then I mean basically the other
alternative is you water them around you
wet oh I mean oh yeah I mean they're
gonna burn their paws wait wait are you
saying are you telling me that Biden was
speaking about how the dog's feet must
felt it's almost like it's almost like
Joe Biden that what is that word called
when you do that
can someone look up the word that that
is being um displayed when Biden feels
empathy for uh that's what it is that's
the word empathy for the dog's feet hmm
especially to spend hours hours out and
search and rescue to find any survivors
or any bodies or anyone that is out
there
these dogs are the real heroes of the
situation and he said hot ground but to
Republicans at some [__] deep state
code of some man who has dementia so
what does it man it's either he's some
Mastermind again or he is full of
dementia and doesn't know what's going
on but the truth of it is
Joe Biden is being empathetic to a dog
oh my God how dare you people well I and
I've said this in the first 30 minutes I
actually don't think Biden should have
went to Hawaii at this point it's a
distraction it takes away from resources
I think they're playing the game of Fox
News in the right wing and they're
playing into their hands when he does
this [__] and the White House thinks
that they have to capitulate to look
like he's empathetic when he can just be
empathetic he doesn't have to pretend he
can just do that he can just be
empathetic he didn't have to go to
Hawaii to to make sure that he's doing
the correct things for Hawaii that's
that's my belief but we have some
breaking news here there's a couple
pieces uh this first piece is from Cruz
citizens
it looks like it looks like the um
internal Secret Service emails that were
obtained by a foyer request from Kirk
from crew uh show special agents in
close Communications with Oath Keepers
leader Stuart Rhodes while failing to
acknowledge the group signs to White
nationalists and clashes with law
enforcement so Secret Service was
coordinating or communicating the leads
to some degree with The Oath Keepers
leader Stuart Rhodes and you guys know
the audience knows we've had Dakota
Adams he's a strange son and his ex-wife
uh Tasha Adams on the show before
talking about Stewart Rhodes
um but apparently these emails so we'll
probably know more about these emails as
they come out as crew releases them but
crew is reporting that there are
internal Secret Service emails
um showing special agents in close
Communications with The Oath Keepers
leader Stuart Rhodes now we know from
The Trial they were looking for a
go-between which hey what better go
between than the guys that are standing
right with Donald Trump I've seen people
who you know just happen to delete those
text messages on January 5th and January
6th whoa that's weird right that don't
don't don't look into that guys don't
feel like it's weird that somebody on
Secret Service detailed happened to of
all days you know delete their messages
on January 5th and January 6. it wasn't
like there was a big event that had been
planned or they were trying to
coordinate with certain people like
oathkeepers proud boys uh with other
people you know like uh you know Roger
Stone or Eastman or anyone else who is
planning to overthrow the government the
other the other the other breaking news
story that we have is from the
Associated Press and this is big news in
the um
in the Russia coup remember this this
happened what was a couple months ago
pagosian was
a lesson probably a couple yeah I don't
know time time right it flies it flies
um so progression and the leader of
Wagner group was marching towards uh uh
the Putin and the capital they're in
Russia and it seemed like there was a
mutiny
um at least a coup at best attempt and
um but there's news now that uh
apparently there's been a jet a Business
Jet crash and it sounds like uh it was a
business [__] in route from Moscow to St
Petersburg it was an accident right oh
it was an accident no CR that crazy
Russian weather and it sounds like
pagosian was on board is that the report
here hang on hang on let me let me take
a quick read I think that was like the
number number one
private jet crashed killing 10 people on
board
um and the mercenary Chief pergosian was
one of the on the passenger list
convenient if he was on board so
forgotian pregosian is dead is that so
Newt Gingrich not dead apparently
pergosian presumed dead at this point
yeah so um that's the news the headline
is
Newt Gingrich not dead yeah darn it
um pregosian dead yeah Putin yeah well I
mean you know I'm I'm not gonna say
uh you know what look we're not gonna
say it was shot down wait look let's
just say what it was it was shot down
the the the positive here is that a a
[__] War monger and a and a [__] a
mercenary and someone who of probably
commits war crimes on The Daily
pregosian is dead
um so it's one less scumbag on the face
of the Earth to me so I don't I don't
want to pretend that I'm not dancing on
his grave because I'm definitely dancing
on his grave I just don't like how it
probably went down you know like um it
could have been it could have been
better if pagosian and Putin were in
like a duel and they shot each other at
the same time that could have been a
better situation I'm just saying instead
of both of them going PPU only one right
PPU right right and did it at the place
is there more breaking news that you
have here is that the ones that you had
in the chat those are the two that okay
good good good good good good all right
so let's get back to
um The Daily stuff here and you can go
you guys I'll let's see I'll retweet
that maybe maybe where'd it go [__] okay
I'll retweet that so you guys can see
both of those um articles one from crew
and then one from the AP there about the
progosian plane crash
okay let's go back to the um there's a
couple more Clips there's one of Matt
gats I want to show you oh my God I
actually love this clip this one was
beautiful
and I've been talking about uh how
unserious these people are for a long
time and here Matt gants is to prove me
wrong let's hear it let's hear it Maddie
let's hear what your chomo mouth has to
tell me about being serious and I think
that if we do not begin this impeachment
work we're going to look unserious as
how serious they're just they're just
now gonna look unserious just now we've
had we've been serious we had a serious
face time we had our serious suit on
right they were serious people they were
serious about knowing how big honor
Biden's [__] was you are not serious
people they are not they're not serious
um and you know I I think I tweeted
something like uh when was the moment
that you thought you were serious when
you were trying to submit a thumb drive
of Hunter Biden's dick pics into
Congressional editors or is that the
time that you thought I don't know I
think the time that he was like we're
serious is when he asked for a party in
from now all the way back to the
beginning of time speaking of that
pardon blankets are for sale now they
are yes they are so go to the attorney
michaels.com that's eternally
michaels.com scan down hit Gabe
Sanchez's if you're wanting a pardon
blank keep warm right and keep safe
right with the pardon blanket and and
Matt Gantz should probably go get one
himself so Matt if you're out there just
go to the Tony michaels.com scan gown
hit Gabe Sanchez merch store it'll take
you through the link tree to the merch
store you'll find the pardon blankets
there buddy if you need a pardon blanket
anyone in the chat if you've committed a
federal crime just know that these
blankets will protect you but if it's a
state level crime these blankets will
not protect you
no it is true so let's look I've I've
had testimonials from from people who
bought it and they're like oh my gosh I
was able to commit so many felonies and
this blanket protected me right you
don't have to run for president for this
blanket to protect you that's the thing
like most most people run for president
to protect themselves from federal
felonies because you know you're immune
when you run for breath that's what
we're supposed to believe but this
blanket actually gives you a a force
field for felony it's crazy it's like
you know some people you know there's
the Iron Dome in Israel this is like the
police Dome storm Virgil on to it says
watch gay become a blanket Tycoon like
Mike Lindell can you imagine pardon
slippers the pardon slippers now
introducing the pardon slippers I mean
you could if you commit if you committed
felonies while wearing certain part in
gear right it would it'd be like the
invisibility cloak and Harry Potter I
see yeah
really get immunity then as well because
people are like oh my god did a ghost do
this what kind of spirit is happening
here this is not a real person that
committed this crime
because nobody could see you you're
invisible immune
I got one more clip and this is all
right all right this clip is gonna piss
everyone off
um but I gotta show it and the reason
why I want to show it is because if
you're wondering
if you're still wondering where the
right wing gets their white Christian
nationalist ideas okay if you're still
wondering that like where do they come
up with this [__]
like Donald Trump is immune and you
can't criminally try him because he's a
former president he's the greatest of
all time and
um I present to you Prince numbnuts
that's when I deemed him in the Tweet uh
here Nick Nick Fuentes Prince numbnuts
listen to what he calls trumpier and how
he
um he's in his racist rant here against
a judge and the uh watch what he calls
Trump here listen to this
you're a [__] immigrant
we have uh we have a black immigrant and
if she's appointed by Obama another
non-citizen
okay so if you didn't catch if you
didn't if you didn't catch it
um chetkin he's calling her an immigrant
oh okay okay
right he's a she's a black immigrant
though as opposed to you know the the
white European ones right yeah
not only is she an immigrant she's a
black one so it's apparently two marks
against fuentes's ideology here which is
uh what's it called Nazism yeah I think
that I think he's a Nazi is what he is
um but watch what he calls Trump here
because he really is defending Trump
against chetkin Because he believes
chudkin is being unfair to uh what does
he call him another
non-naturalized non-citizen from Kenya
presiding over a case of a former
president
and a job Creator and a billionaire and
an all-around Titan admired man
and this
person
is going to throw a wrench in and so she
controls the campaign that she's going
to talk to the king of America like this
like he's like they pull them over for
having tinted windows did he did he did
he just say Donald Trump did he say
did he say the word king of America is
that what he said I could have swore
that's what he said let's keep listening
maybe he says it again maybe he says it
again you're a criminal like anybody
else uh no [__] he's a king of America
you stupid [__] go back to Jamaica
uh again if you're still standing around
wondering where your [__] Papaw is
getting these ideas that Donald Trump
cannot be touched and no one can touch
him because he's some Almighty Force
it's coming from Nick Fuentes the Nazi
your grandpa may not know it but it's
coming it's rolling this [__] rolls down
hill and your grandpa is getting caught
up in the [__] delusional ball and this
is it you know I try to warn you about
these things I try to show you these
things I just I just
I find it hilarious that this little
[__] [__] is wearing a Golden Gloves
hoodie on yeah like this guy has ever
shown his face in a ring and ever
[__] put boxing gloves let me see if
I can get a good shot of that uh on a
still here because he's he's uh he's
where it is I get the best Stills look
at that
Golden Gloves boxing establishments in
Chicago now he hails from the same part
of the country that gave Sanchez Hills
from yeah yeah yeah yeah does that does
that make you disappointed or yeah like
that happens you know yeah dude it's
also uh I'm pretty sure hold on let me
just confirm this I'm pretty sure
um our boy
Fuentes well not just Fuentes oh okay I
just want to make sure just want to make
sure
someone else or someone [__] Charlie
Kirk oh yeah he's yeah he's from uh an
upscale he comes from Arlington Heights
what did scribe Arlington Heights for us
it's a [__] upper middle class area
it's a suburb of Chicago it's you know a
very cookie cutter and it's [__] but
yeah it's like upper middle class
definitely coming out of that there's a
lot of white people there so so Charlie
Kirk
Charlie Kirk is accustomed to privilege
is what you're saying oh yeah dude born
into it and the same goes the same goes
for Nick Fuentes because where was he
born he was born in uh he was LaGrange
which again like these these are white
areas these are the it's it's almost
like it's almost like they were
indoctrinated into some sort of 80 by
80.82 white
now before we go
uh you tweeted this the other day we we
covered a story on Monday about Nick
sorter he when he was attacked when he
was attacked by someone in Hawaii on
Steve Bannon show and Steve Bannon kept
roll and Steve Ben didn't give a [__]
how pathetic yeah because he knew he was
like this is like TV and uh he's like
either way this goes either he gets his
ass kicked oh great [__] and nothing
happens even better right so Nick goes
on Charlie Kirk show speaking of that
little white privilege cut Charlie Kirk
um he goes on his show and Charlie's
like and I show that clip yesterday and
he's like oh that was so bad I can't
believe that guy was trying to attack
you and he's trying to he was trying to
do a full magazine of assault questions
on you I mean it was almost like he
gunned you down with questions he asked
you like two questions and they were
really hard like why are you here and
why are you taking up resource it was
difficult for you to answer those
questions but you pointed out that Nick
in this Saga has taken one more step
here
uh you tweeted Nick sorter I am here to
help the people of Maui also next order
send me money in support of our work
he's just another right-wing Drifter
here's his tweet here Sheriff you've
been asking by DM how you can support
our work out here and I'm so humbled by
that none of that happened yeah I'll
take uh things that never happened for a
thousand please right
and here's the best ways send me money I
will not pocket even one dollar dude by
you getting it in your in your [__]
PayPal and your cash yeah that's you
pocketing the money right what you're
saying is you will give every dollar and
not only that but this next line goes
against what he just said right all
unused donations will be unused right
who's gonna audit this because if you're
saying if he is
I don't know if you remember this but
the guy that came up to him the other
day when he was doing the interview with
Steve Bannon he said hey you said you
were sleeping in a tent somewhere now I
haven't confirmed that I haven't looked
it up but the fact that he was like oh
uh
you claim that you were doing this Nick
sorter was
if you notice in the video there's this
like little building there and what I
believe is that's the hotel that he
later said he was staying at yeah
because he says it on Charlie Kirk show
the hotel the hotel how did he find me I
don't know you doxed me people have been
talking nobody docks you and the guy was
like you posted a photo of yourself by
the beach with a palm tree I live on the
[__] Island I know where that [__] is
even if it's burnt down
I got a bonehead but uh Nick is a
typical victim here he he follows it up
like I'd also like to potentially bring
other independent journalists out here
to support to provide support what what
is a independent journalist going to do
this Provide support on the ground for
the people of Maui other than you lying
about them you [__] fool and sucking
up resources next order you're not a
journalist you're a grifter and you're a
poser and you're a fake a phony and a
fraud sorry buddy yeah talk to you
before I've heard you I've listened to
you I've I've went back and I'm Nick
shorter and uh I mean you have to you
have to look at the facts here no you
don't work on facts man right she Hunter
Biden's [__] is really big and I want to
know how Hunter buying [__] how big it
is and we're gonna hold the Twitter
space uh for everyone to get here your
opinion I'm just asking questions
how how big Hunters Biden's [__] is
that's all I want to know how big it is
it's not that I'm obsessed with this
[__] or anything this one not big it's
not only have all the contents of right
100 laptop and my picture of his [__]
and I I've analyzed I've analyzed I've
gone in pixel by pixel shaping in the
dimension being that penis is ah Nick
Nick get off the island and when you
come back to the States stop stop
obsessing about hunter's [__] it's not
doing anything it's not doing any good
and it doesn't make you a journalist to
be obsessed with Hunter Biden's dick
pics it just doesn't
what does make you a journalist
it's not watching this either this is
not news folks we are making fun of the
news here at the Tony Michaels podcast
but we do it every single weekday and we
do it with style
and with Panache rock and roll and
Tattoos sometimes sometimes we're stoned
so hit that subscribe button hit the
thumbs up if you like it if you don't
like it [__] you hit the thumbs down
we'd like for you to at least engage and
support the show also if you like to get
on the super chats go to venmo chat go
to venmo super Chaco michaels.com the
Tony michaels.com send us a message
there and while you're messaging bye God
you better get over on the Discord that
is where the chat never stops it does
not stop
over there on Discord so get over there
on Discord let me see if I can put the
um if I can get it here I can get the
link to the Discord I can put it in your
channel wow wow so click on the link
here and go to the Discord server now
where the chat never stops there was a
troll in there this morning they used to
be on YouTube oh yeah
it was kind of fun they were [__]
with him for a while and then they
decided they were going to tell people
to die and [__] so they showed him to
the door and opened the door with their
[__] head and threw them out of the
Discord server
um listen I'll put up with some trolls
for a little bit but you get out of hand
and you don't behave
yeah yeah gone you're gone you're gonna
go in the trash you Nazi yeah I mean so
you ain't respecting people then uh
right and that's the thing on our
Discord server we keep it we keep it
light we keep it funny just like the
show here but as soon as the trolls get
in and they start not behaving and they
start acting like you sound like Nazis
hasta la vista baby
that's how we handle sorry I just saw
the mighty Librarians Post in the live
show chat yeah and it's the [__] Lion
King yeah [__] you and it says get
the [__] out of here ah so if you want
it you know that's the unique thing
about the Discord chat during the live
show is you get to put gifts in there
you get to put your memes in there you
don't get to do that on the YouTube chat
so if like you speak and GIF or meme
yeah the chat dude I went to college and
I got a [__] major and a
concentration yeah dude right okay I got
you well
manga speaks victim ease over on the
live show chat on Discord they speak GIF
and meme so if you want to speak that
way if you want to communicate that way
with the live chat as we're going with
the show get your ass over to the
Discord where it never stops and really
honestly it's like 24 7 over there I can
never stops it just keeps going and
going and going and going so join the
Discord join the [__] community over
there it's [__] free it doesn't cost
you a single thing to get over there and
get in the chat and and and if you want
to box some trolls when they come in Bam
Bam Bam throw some punches at some Nazi
trolls when they come in the Discord get
in on that too before My Librarian or
skip over there tosses them out of the
Discord so yeah
oh God
same to you same time same place
tomorrow
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon